hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match between uh johanna blumenthal
punch
paul charles morphy and this is the 11th
the game
uh so far out of the ten games they
played morphe one eight and
uh yo hanyakov won two uh and which is
of course a problem for him like we
mentioned as he wants to win the match
and show that he is in fact uh stronger
than morphy
uh unlike what we've seen in their uh
match eight years ago
so this one uh it's a great game it
features a brilliant move
uh one that is very deep so
we will have a very very nice positive
video moment uh but that's pretty much
it for the for the intro
uh one more day uh until we publish the
first chapter of age of kaiser
but that will have to wait for tomorrow
and i i will make a separate video on
that uh to tell you guys more about it
so uh let's check it out elemental opens
with e4
and for this game morphe goes for the
sicilian defense with c5 and the media
the d4
this is how they treated the sicilian in
those days we have captures
knight to f3 and now e6 allowing the the
recapture now uh we basically transpose
into a normal sicilian knight captures
we have knight to c6
uh going into the taimano variation and
now knight the b5 preparing knight to d6
with
check and here a6 morphe just allows it
he knows there is nothing to worry about
regarding this check knight to d6 with
check
bishop captures and now queen captures
and morphy
immediately goes for a queen trade queen
to e7
so now uh he either wants uh to go
straight into the end game or
white will uh move the queen and then
the game continues tonight
queen back to g3 and now knight to f6
queen f6 is uh what was played
in modern days but this uh uh this
wasn't actually played all that much as
white didn't really get all that much
from
from this so there's not much theory on
this so we have knight to f6
and now knight to c3 and it is as of
move 9 that this position has never been
reached again
so d5 uh morphy now goes for the dream
move you
you play the silly and you want to
execute d5 as soon as possible and here
e5 not allowing morphe and easy trade in
the center
knight the h5 attacking the queen and
queen f3 and here
already we've reached the position from
the thumbnail
now the knight is under attack and
morphy defends it with the g6 but
this uh this gives uh uh lointel an
opportunity for a brilliant move
uh so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea
uh well i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you uh who were able
to do it congratulations on being
brilliant
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's g4
but the g4 is much more complicated than
it seems because
it seems like the knight has only one
square g7 but
the truth is that the knight doesn't
even have the g7 square
because if morphe goes back knights to
g7 then queen f6
wins the game because well the knight is
under attack and you're gonna win the
night and there is not much you can do
uh to defend the knight for example if
you defended just the bishop h6 and
again the knight has nowhere to go
and if you trade queens the knight still
doesn't have anywhere to go and you're
just gonna lose the knight because the
pawns uh
the pawn covers all of the squares the
king covers the e8 square
and the knight is just trapped and it
doesn't help if you don't defend it with
the rook
uh if you try pretty much anything just
captures and captures again the knight
is trapped
and other than this you could also
castle but it doesn't help
bishop h6 threatening checkmate and
again the knight has nowhere to go
you could move it i mean you have to
move it if you want to defend against
checkmate trading queens again
just pawn captures the knight has
nowhere to go and if this then you
happily trade queens and pick up the
rook
bishop captures king captures and of
course you're up the exchange now and
the winning the game
so uh g4 really a brilliant move it's
not
to say that it's uh not without counter
play there is one move for morphe that
allows him
reasonable counterplay but morphe didn't
go for that one d4
here with the with the idea that you you
give up upon and you go for
some sort of uh some sort of an end game
for example captures captures and
captures and now queen before
uh this is possible uh but not the
morphe's liking
uh morphe goes and knight captures on e5
he uh
grabs a pawn and he will grab yet
another pawn for the price of one knight
so queen back to e2 now both knights are
under attack and here you don't really
have all that much to do so morphy grabs
on g4 we have queen captures and now
e5 so morphy grabs two pawns uh he
sacrificed the knight and he has a
massive pawn center he wants to
start rolling those pawns down the board
as the white king is still in the center
of the board so it does make sense
uh queen to a4 with check bishop to d7
and now queen to b3 putting pressure on
the b7 pawn but morphy
said uh i didn't sacrifice a piece to
you know uh
count pawns so i'm just gonna continue
with d4
uh we have queen captures on b7 now of
course if you capture the queen can just
capture the rook with check
so castles now the rooks are nicely
connected and now
knight to d5 attacking the queen here
queen to d6 you still have to keep an
eye on the bishop
and now comes bishop to g2 again an
excellent move by lemental this is the
only
move that gives white advantage for
example you could
try some bishop to e2 ideas with some
crazy
uh plans of bishop capture spawn
captures then you sacrifice the queen
queen captures knight f6 check picks up
the queen
such things are in the position however
rook to be
just uh wins for black because the queen
is trapped or rather
uh if you want to save the queen you
will have to give up the knight either
by doing something like this or maybe 97
check and then you make some room for
the queen but still the
the position would be lost uh so instead
uh after this idea uh uh after this
um queen to d6 we have bishop to g2 now
the knight is protected
uh rook here would make no sense as just
queen to c7 the knight is protected
so here morphy plays e4 and he dares
elemental
to capture the bishop uh but if you
capture if you capture the pawn at
again have have an eye on that knight on
b5
uh then bishop captures a rook e8 and
you have big problems your king is still
on e1
so here uh instead uh instead of
capturing we have
c4 and this is the only good move for
white and lomento plays it low until is
like a machine this game
he's like uh morphy gave him that one
opening that
one opportunity to play g4 and uh from
that moment on it's all
it's all yohanyakov so here the knight
is defended
if you capture al passon then just the
knight captures nothing really
happening here so after c4 morphe goes
for f5 he is now going all in there's no
going back
uh and queen to b4 now lumentel wants to
trade queens we have queen to e5
and now queen to e7 again with the queen
trade offer
bishop e6 and queen to sorry wrong queen
queen to c7 now offering the queen trade
queen g7 you can't really avoid it
uh not not much squares left so here
morphy says okay we trade about we trade
on my terms
so i can at least get my knight back
into the game so queen captures knight
captures
and now knight the b6 attacking the rook
while also saving the pawn and also
preparing to advance the pawn as the c8
square is covered also by the knight
so rook ab8 and c5 fixing everything
with knight to h5 by morphe again
bringing the knight back into the game
but now b4
defending the pass pawn so you don't
have to worry about anything on the
queen side
anymore and king of seven now morphy
starts bringing the king into the game
uh and castles by logan tal we have g5
and now rook to d1 going after the pawn
here
and uh well he could play d3
uh it is a possibility just f3 breaks up
the pawn chain
uh so here morphe decides to go for
something radical he plays
rook f2d8 first defends the pawn
but gives up the g5 pawn so he wants to
open up the g
file and like i said morphe is all in as
of this point so bishop captures and now
rook back to g8 would be great if you
could
grab hold of the g file so h4 defending
that bishop and now rook g6 morphe gives
yet another pawn to get the other rook
to the g file and he's betting
putting all his hopes on this h6 move
that the bishop will move and you will
bust open on the g
file and emerge victorious however
rook captures on d4 by lementhal uh rook
beat the g8 and now now comes knight to
d7 threatening knights to e5 with this
beautiful fork
and uh should morphy capture then it's
just check and you don't have time to
push h6 king f8 and now rook 8 to d1
and it's all over if you if you go for
h6 which is basically your only contra
plan
just rook b7 threatening checkmate and
now you have to abandon the plan of
capturing the bishop so you have to go
help out with the defense but
just check captures uh or even rather
you could first
deliver check bishop captures an h6
check and the king has nowhere to go
you're going to have to block knight g7
but then just pretty much anything
anything goes just captures captures and
now you can capture here
uh you're up so much material you don't
you don't even care you're up to
you're up a bishop pair which is not
very often
uh seen in chess so after 97 morphe
decides to go for rook captures on g5 a
last
resort move but we have h captures on g5
rook captures and now came to h2 so
unpinning
and okay morphe still has some pressure
here uh two pieces and a rook and some
pawns in front of the white king but
he's down a whole rook so
it's not going to be easy knight f4
preparing to capture here
and bishop to f1 controlling all the
squares the knight has
rook h5 check king g3 and now knight the
d5 preparing
f4 uh so of course love intel plays f4
himself
e captures on f3 alpha song and now
knight the
uh knights the e5 with check uh king of
six
and now knight captures on f3
recapturing the pawn with the knight we
rook to h6 and now rook to e1
uh now uh saying okay i'm going to
position my rooks nicely if you move the
knight i'm just going to play rook d6
attack the pin bishop
so it's not going to be easy so rook g6
checked by morphe king f2
and now knight to c3 uh morphe goes
after the a2 pawn
uh but uh low intel just allows it he
plays bishop to d3
he says okay if you go after the pawn
i'm just going to play rogue d6 and
that's it
you can't even on pin or anything i mean
it's just game over
if you want pin to defend with the rook
just uh 95 check picks up the rook
so after bishop d3 morphy played bishop
to d5
but now comes bishop captures an f5
a nice clean idea uh saying that okay if
you capture
i'm up so much material that i can even
give you a full piece just to go knight
h4
check when when uh the exchange here
king of six captures captures and i have
two rooks for a bishop in the knight of
course completely winning
so after bishop captures on f5 morphy
moved the rook brook g7 but now
rook to f4 was played and it was in this
position that
paul charles murphy resigned the game
and it's not some sort of a game where
he
like made a terrible mistake or
something he just allowed for that g4 to
happen and he didn't reply with
with that d4 idea which would uh which
would basically force him to play
an endgame upon down from basically from
the start of the game
so he decided he's going to go out
swinging and
you know went out swinging he did uh but
yeah
really crazy stuff here he resigns
because he his king has no squares this
is taken this is taken by the knight
this is taken by the by the bishop
this is taken by the rook so nowhere to
go nasty discoveries are coming and you
are you are getting checkmated very soon
just to make it fun as we are kind of
calling this uh lointel's immortal
uh even if you try king f7 to try and
find some sort of a safe heaven just
bishop captures and h7 is checkmate as
these two squares are covered the rooks
are slicing all the way here
uh there is nothing to be done here so
excellent game by loving
finding that g for idea brilliant stuff
and seeing everything
uh very very incredible uh so yeah that
was uh 11th
game uh the result is now eight wins
morphe
three wins elemental so anything can
still happen
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank david kimura
andreas uh ivy nicolas kifa and
even sterling for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day